so we're investing in our Court UK
facility so both in Burton Latimer and
Corby in Northamptonshire that will
enable us to bring new interesting
variants of Weetabix to our court UK
market but also we export to 80 markets
around the world so that will enable us
to do that particularly China which is a
big opportunity for us and we you know
we doubled the business there last year
so we're seeing a growing demand and
desire for British foods in in places
like China but still the majority over
70% of our businesses is the UK we've
seen the market is relatively flat but
if you look at the sort of healthier
brands it's not just our brands of we'd
a big help and other brands there's
still that growing desire and we're
seeing a growth there we believe that we
can grow yet further and that's that's
what this investments all about what
about the relationship with the
supermarket's so we had a very well
publicized spat just before Christmas
between Tesco and Unilever over the
price of Marmite are you feeling under
pressure from supermarkets to reduce
your prices or keep them constant I
think there's a constant dialogue you
know there are incredibly important
partners in the process I think that was
a slightly different thing related to
the brexit impact and so on but you know
what we try and do working closely with
all all our customers is how can we grow
add value and defend the categories
we're involved in so you know
particularly the larger UK supermarkets
that have the challenge of the
discounters entering in you know our
role is to work with all customers and
find a way that we can help them be
successful in the category that we
operate in but presumably you are facing
some cost pressures as a result of the
weaker pound wheat prices for example
absolutely so the one thing we do know
about brexit from our side of the fence
is that obviously Sterling's weakened
the majority of our raw materials are
either dollar or euro based commodities
and therefore we have some impact there
but our primary role would always be to
look to offset that inflation internally
by trying to run the business more
efficiently more effectively it was
reported just before Christmas that your
majority Chinese shareholder has put
their stake up for sale what's the
situation on that right now
well we don't you know comment on rumor
and speculation the one thing I do know
about both
investors is there backing this
investment and they believe in the long
term growth prospects for our brands in
the UK and as I said earlier on in our
discussion
you know our export as well as you know
what we're trying to do in China and
this investments how many more jobs will
it create well we're just working
through the finer details of that there
will be some incremental jobs associated
the most important thing is we have
incremental capacity and really to the
employees to all stakeholders including
our farmers because we source all of our
grain from within 50 miles of the plant
this is ensuring the business is
successful for their future so some of
its additional compass' capacity some of
its making sure that our process
continue to run as efficiently and
effectively as possible